[Musique]
bonjour thomas porte merci de répondre à
nos questions ce matin sur arte france
cet appel concerne principalement l'est
parisien comment s'annonce le trafic
aujourd'hui toute façon le trafic dans
cette période il est il est restreint il
est réduit et la mobilisation des
cheminots elle et elle est importante
puisque aujourd'hui on est sur une
répression syndicale vous l'avais dit
dans votre titre
on a cinq militants qui sont menacés de
procédures disciplinaires dont un qui
est menacé de licenciement c'est
extrêmement grave et c'est c'est une
attaque encore une fois de la direction
de la sntf en cette période sanitaire où
les cheminots autre chose à faire et ils
sont sur le terrain pour permettre aux
usagers de prendre le train dans des
bonnes conditions
la sncf se livre à une chasse aux
syndicalistes totalement inacceptable
alors vous parlez
de d'actes infondées également de
répression syndicale
ça veut dire quoi exactement ça veut
dire qu'aujourd'hui on est sur une
situation où la direction de la sncf
reproche en réalité à des cheminots
d'avoir occupé illégalement un locaux
sur une journée ce qui est absolument
pas vrai puisque ces locaux ils
appartiennent depuis 1986 ils ont été
données par une convention à l'époque au
comité d'établissement puis transféré ce
qu'on appelle le crs c'est-à-dire les
nouvelles instances représentatives du
personnel sont des salles qui permettent
aux cheminots d'avoir des activités
sociales d'ailleurs ce sont les salaires
une part des salaires des cheminots qui
paye aujourd'hui des factures dire
c'était et de gaz la sncf souhaite et
les récupérer pour permettre d'autres
activités mais elle s'était engagée à
remettre le nombre de mètres carrés
disponibles pour que les cheminots
puissent continuer à exercer des
activités économiques sociales et de
loisirs et aujourd'hui ce n'est pas fait
il ya eu simplement une action
symbolique qui a été menée aucunement
aucun cheminots ont été empêchés d'aller
au travail
il n'y a pas eu de violences verbales ou
physiques donc on comprend pas bien la
sanction simplement on voit derrière ce
qui se passe c'est à dire que une chasse
aux syndicalistes qui est déjà à
l'oeuvre depuis plusieurs années à la
sncf et qui sous couvert de cette lutte
contre le corps navires us la direction
de la sncf en profite pour pour essayer
de faire tomber celles et ceux qui
aujourd'hui mène la bataille des
entreprises pour avoir un service public
par des conditions de sécurité et pour
défendre un véritable droit au transport
avec cet appel à la grève pour
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous ne vous
entendez pas un mauvais accueil de la
part de l'opinion publique et des
usagers qui sont déjà contraints comme
vous l'avez dit à une circulation
réduite déconfinement oblige donc
aujourd'hui effectivement à cette
question se pose vous savez à chaque
mobilisation sociale
nous on nous oppose le fait de savoir si
si il va y avoir une opinion publique ou
pas avec nous je crois que dans cette
période de crise beaucoup de citoyens
ont aussi compris le besoin d'avoir des
services publics le rôle important
qu'ils jouent dans des périodes comme
celle que nous connaissons
et si la mobilisation des cheminots elle
est aujourd'hui important test s'inscrit
dans cette bataille là pour rendre des
services publics accessibles à tous
et quand on attaque des syndicalistes
qui défendent l'intérêt général en
réalité on attaque
effectivement les usagers parce que
derrière ce qu'on veut faire tomber
c'est le le transport public donc je
crois qu'il ya pas à reposer les
les autres les bouteilles sont menées de
front commun elles répondent à l'intérêt
général
mais qu'est ce que vous répondez à ceux
qui disent que ceux qui jugent qu'il est
irresponsable de manifester en pleine
crise sanitaire qu'il faut rester unis
pour relancer l'économie du pays
je crois que je crois que les discours
de l'unité des manuels mcrory n'engage
que celui qui les fait c'est à dire lui
aujourd'hui il n'y aura pas de
mobilisation physique sur le terrain du
qu'effectivement les cheminots sont
respectueux des conditions sanitaires et
n'y aura pas de manifestation simplement
l'appel à l'unité nous on n'y est pas
favorable sur le fond c'est à dire que
ok il faut un rassemblement large mais
nous on porte l'idée dans l'ensemble des
forces progressistes qui s'inscrit dans
notre projet de société qui à l'encontre
de ce que fait manuel macro et de son
gouvernement
d'ailleurs vous avez bien vu les
annonces on ne parle pas de chiffres
pour sauver l'essentiel on parle pas de
développer le très bon papa de
développer le fret
on a besoin aujourd'hui de transports
publics dans ce pays de transport qui
soit propre écologiquement qui répondent
aux besoins de mobilité et la seule
annonce qu'on a eu du présent de la sntr
c'est qu'il va falloir serrer la
ceinture et faire des économies
donc nous aujourd'hui on se reconnaît
pas dans ses propos la du gouvernement
merci thomas porte d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
responsable du collectif cheminots au
pcf